hi I'm Alec Baldwin and I wanted to
begin the tributes tonight by saying
that as an actor I dreamed years ago of
being both talented enough and lucky
enough to have a specific type of career
to move almost at will between stage and
screen and to leave a powerful memorable
impression with the force and dexterity
of one's work to play barbarians and
kings champions and chauffeurs the
apotheosis of the dark side and a cold
warrior in American intelligence two
equally incalculable effect I wanted
James Earl Jones's career that is what I
wanted that is what every actor wants
some actors become stars who burn
brightly for a distinct period of time
that enter a phase where they try hard
to get it back James Earl Jones never
had to get it back because he never lost
it from his first film role in Kubrick's
dr. Strangelove in 1964 through his Tony
award-winning performance in the great
white hope on Broadway and then through
decades of staggering roles from a
Shakespeare to Star Wars James Earl
Jones is one of the greatest actors in
American history and an example to all
and an example to all by doing not by
saying but by doing when I worked with
James in the movie Hunt for Red October
in 1989 I waited for that moment when I
could have him alone to pick his brains
to ask the great man for some advice and
we were standing outside standing
outside a stage at Paramount and the
moment came and we were smoking a
cigarette together out on the alleyway
and I finally said to him what advice
would you give to me as an actor and he
stared at me with that face of his and
took the longest pause you could ever
measure and he said what advice would I
give you as an actor and my heart was
racing I said yes yes what advice would
you give me as an actor and he said my
advice to you would be to quit smoking
and all the rest of it I learned just
from watching James Earl Jones
congratulations to James Earl Jones
you
you